et puis air france innove soucieuse de
faciliter le voyage en avion des
personnes âgées et handicapées
la france en effet équipe actuellement
ces appareils long-courriers d'une
chaise mobile destiné à faciliter les
déplacements dans l'aéroport mais aussi
à l'intérieur de la cabine des
explications de laurent bustier
la voilà donc cette chaise de transfert
qui depuis 2 - équipe tous les avions
long courrier d'air france boeing 747 et
airbus maniable et légère elle ne pèse
que 7 kilos et demi elle est destinée
aux passagers handicapés ou à mobilité
réduite et a pour but de simplifier de
pénaliser leurs voyages en avion pour en
bénéficier ils doivent en faire la
demande au moment de l'achat du billet
en présentant une carte frais mec
délivré pour plusieurs mois par un
médecin de la compagnie à son arrivée à
l'aéroport ou plus précisément dès son
passage aux banques d'enregistrement
le passager handicapé est totalement
prise en charge
une fois l'avion vole la chaise de
transférer mise à disposition par les
hôtesses et les stewards une
manipulation assez facile qui ne prend
que quelques instants
ce siège me permet de circuler dans la
viande de pouvoir les aux toilettes
lorsque je le désire sans qu'il y ait de
transfert sans qu'il y ait de
manipulation s'inquiète portage donc ça
me permet d'utiliser tout ce que
toutes les possibilités offertes aux
autres passagers et donc plus autonome
je suis autonome à partir du moment où
ce siège est à bord voilà donc